[Music]
London is hosting an International
Conference to help Ukraine recover from
the conflict the British prime minister
Rishi sunak is expected to unveil a
financial assistance package including a
three billion dollar credit from the
World Bank and currently the U.S
Secretary of State Anthony blinken is
speaking at that conference let's listen
in adopting these and other critical
reforms to increase Ukraine's
transparency competitiveness to bolster
the rule of law
will help attract more private
investment
and that is essential and you heard it
from my colleagues
governments are doing a lot
International financial institutions are
doing a lot
both of us have a usually important role
to play in Ukraine's recovery but it is
not enough
only the private sector
can mobilize the level of investment
necessary to meet the country's massive
needs
the diverse participation of the private
sector here today in this conference
shows the growth opportunity that Global
firms and investors see in the future of
Ukraine in the future of its people
but make no mistake
all of these reforms and Recovery
efforts
depend on Ukraine having the capacity to
deter and defend against future attacks
by Russia
that's why even as we invest in
Ukraine's immediate and long-term
recovery
we also have to build a Ukrainian
military that is strong enough
to protect Ukraine's sovereignty its
territorial integrity and its
independence
not just to defend Ukraine's land
but to defend all that ukrainians are
building and will build on that land
it's also why the United States is
committed to working to build support
for a just and Lasting peace in Ukraine
the core elements of which I outlined a
couple of weeks ago in Helsinki
those include a piece that upholds the
United Nations Charter and its
fundamental principles sovereignty
territorial Integrity Independence that
addresses both accountability and
Reconciliation
that ensures Ukraine's full
participation and ascent
and that supports Ukraine's
reconstruction and Recovery
even as we rally around Ukraine's
recovery
we must not lose sight of why that is
necessary in the first place
indeed
even as we come together here in London
committed to supporting Ukraine's build
up Russia continues to try to burn it
down
so
let's be clear
Russia is causing Ukraine's destruction
and Russia will eventually bear the cost
of Ukraine's reconstruction
until that time
until that time we will continue to
stand with the people of Ukraine as they
make the greatest sacrifices to defend
to rebuild
to reimagine their country
and in doing so
we will reaffirm the principle at the
heart of the international order
that people in every nation can write
their own future
free from aggression free from coercion
free from intimidation
that is a recovery well worth our robust
and enduring support thank you very much
[Applause]
the U.S Secretary of State Lincoln was
just addressing a conference taking
place right now in London and we had
heard from the British prime minister
Rishi sunak earlier on and he's expected
to be unveiling a financial assistance
package including a three billion dollar
credit uh from the World Bank for
Ukraine so that conference still
underway but let's bring in our
correspondent Nadeem Baba who's standing
by for us outside the venue in London to
tell us what we've heard so far from the
delegates and the demon and who's in
attendance
create a new innovative
well Doreen obviously those words from
Secretary of State blinken raising some
of the crucial themes over this two-day
conference he said that clearly uh in
his eyes and his allies his partner's
eyes Russia will have to bear the cost
of reconstructing Ukraine's economy but
in the short term obviously what he's
saying is that the private sector will
have to play the major role in stepping
in in promising to invest in Ukrainian
companies and the like so this is a
diplomatic event it's also a business
event Rishi sunac earlier on the prime
minister of the UK before he introduced
president zielinski via video conference
prime minister sunac reminded people of
the advances that Ukraine had been
making in sectors like green energy but
then reminding people of the devastating
effects on the economy of 16 months of
War GDP down by almost 30 percent so
there are people here who are experts in
fields such as green energy there are
CEOs of major International companies of
course there are the politicians
secretary of state blinken will be
meeting his UK German and French
counterparts as part of the Quad to
discuss things like how to use
um Russian assets legally but behind the
scenes it's all about pledging the money
and particularly from those private
companies that's what Ukraine wants to
hear right now right so how much is
being promised overall
well there are huge figures involved
let's just look at the short term the
World Bank is saying that the
Reconstruction effort will need at least
14 billion dollars uh beyond that the
Ukrainian government the prime minister
of Ukraine who's speaking here shortly
uh estimates that the Reconstruction
will need at least 750 billion US
dollars a recent study involving the UN
and the EU and other institutions put it
uh lower at around
440 billion US Dollars staggering
figures nonetheless on top of that of
course many countries are pledging uh
Military Support to Ukraine and the
total investment will therefore depend
on how long the fighting continues
that's the background to all of this and
that's what nobody can really answer for
sure so the promises that Russia will
pay well they're hard to back up right
now but there are efforts underway to
try to get to to use frozen assets and
the like alongsides the uh the
involvement of the private sector here
okay thank you so much Nadeem for that
update from London so while that
conference gets underway in the UK
there's been a drone strike on a
building in russian-controlled Donetsk
and we have our Ali Hashem who's joining
us live from there so Ali is this the
first time we see this kind of attack on
Russian control Donetsk
well this is the first time a drone
attack uh a Target targets uh place here
in bunetsk in the city of dunyatz this
is a building we're just we're standing
in front of it you can see the scene
here maybe our cameraman could show us
the building also
um just after midnight a drone stroke
this building the 20th floor and it was
uh completely burnt out and but there
are no casualties as we understood now
during the past days there were shelling
around this area this is the center of
the city of dunyetsk there are shellings
artillery is is being used in shelling
the city but this is the first time a
drone at drone targets a certain place
in the city and too many over here this
is a kind of an escalation well when it
comes in parallel with other attacks in
in Moscow as we heard today and also in
Crimea there is a there is a context for
it I would like to show you the parts of
this drone that hit the uh the building
here
this is a handmade drone as we
understood this is the motherboard and
these are some partitions there were
uh kind of bullets inside it however as
we said there are no casualties reported
now during the during yesterday for
example there were several attacks
artillery attacks in inside the city in
dunyetsk for example in the neighborhood
of gifscia and other other neighborhoods
where one person was killed and there
were several
reported injured so this is this is the
situation here now okay thank you so
much Ali has some reporting for us from
Donetsk